hello and happy Monday happy Monday
we're background we're back so review
and bar goes up for four car five it is
heads review in progress is up right now
currently at a nine however we got a
definitely check out you know
connectivity of some co-op stuff
probably and all that fun stuff but we
figure let's check out your later game
save we're not gonna spoil story right
we're just gonna do all this side stuff
we'll check out some of the vehicles you
bought will boomer there yeah I got all
the animals so I can show you each one
of those just you know what what it's
like to explore Montana that's what
that's what we're gonna do okay
with yeah cuz when we started the game
we was very very early on so what I had
was just like bare minimum perks but now
if you look here like I had a lot of the
good stuff and you still got pointy suit
I got some got eight to spend yeah
there's a whole bunch so I have a lot of
cool stuff here I personally am more a
stealth sniper type of player so I have
like this dope ass rifle I just
liberated this but yeah let's do let's
talk to her and see she wants this is
great so this is one the guns for hire
pops always said as long as we keep
believing in each other there's still
hope if we stick together look out for
one another
can't we'll never break us but if you
ever need help give me a call I got your
back
oh that's spray paint a gun must be a
skin yeah so I have a couple of those
like guns you can get that kind of
pimped out I think they're called
legendary I want to say they are but uh
let's go ahead and show off so yeah
here's sweet here's I got into missing a
couple he's a he's got a he's real
casual he's real cash but he's got a
flamethrower Danny that's pretty lit and
that's Herc who was in like the last Far
Cry 4 he was in that I can't believe I
can't remember fusing the other ones but
he's a wuzzy rock here oh Jesus pure
destruction RPGs love it bow and arrow
sniper he'll do airstrikes boomers like
you're good hunting dog that dog I do
like peaches peaches will stealth take
down
spring spring peaches you know you don't
get to level them up the only thing you
can level up as a perk is their respawn
rate so if they go down or you swap them
out they will become faster so like
she'll automatically Crouch any tall
grass and stuff that's a good girl oh
god this would never work out see all
those videos really yeah this is my pet
this is my pet cougar it's everything's
great and then you know now my face is
gone uh-oh
there's gonna have his is pretty great
also just so you guys know I'll be
monitoring that YouTube and twitch and
GameSpot so we're in the but but so if
you guys have any questions or warning
that for Rob hit me up oh god oh I'm
getting run over oh my god how are you
still alive I don't know oh that's a
pretty tame like healing animation
compared to some of those other games oh
this is story try a cutaway feel like
yeah you probably show you way to go rob
weight a way to go well so these story
beats happen automatically
now I think I remember you guys talking
about it kind of like you think you're
gonna die and all that stuff and I think
you're kind of meant and that just
happens I'm I've muted the audio so that
you guys don't hear anything because I
might be a liar to you guys but yeah
thank you guys are tuning in we're live
every day at 11 a.m.
Rob has not beat the game yet so I can't
answer how long it'll take you soap but
if you look at gamespot.com
you have an article about it so how do
you how are you gonna circumvent this
I'm gonna do this yeah but once you
still run into them now I can go to
different area right there's not much I
can do about this oh there's definitely
something you can do about it I can go
back I say alright we're back or are we
not bad no not quite a camera didn't see
anything there there's no anything
happening there yeah I don't think you
can Skippy let me do this
I know load your save yeah yeah I know
Louise tell me about it I asked if he
was prepared of course he wasn't throw
him under the bus that's how it goes I
don't think that's gonna work
I actually I actually think you have to
like back all the way out and you up and
like re-upload or redownload your save
you know what I mean mmhmm yeah
so we're doing that right now we're
redownload in a save all I hear is
screaming yeah you'll hear you're
probably earth at a lot though in this
game oh yeah not a big deal I think you
guys are for tuning in though thank you
for tuning in
apologies he's not that sorry Hey look
I'm half sorry yeah yeah we'll probably
be shooting for high five tomorrow still
so for four different purposes that will
probably play co-op tomorrow yeah and
show us on the PC I know people want to
see that including myself
so I hear it's running pretty well nice
okay Jade Rossi wants to know if it's
worth the money like anything the thing
I keep telling people is that having
played for and primal like I fell off
and got burn out pretty early on I want
to say like maybe like 10 hours in yeah
I am past 10 hours I'm still like
itching to play and that's because of
the fact that it's like unlike an
open-world Ubisoft game where everything
is wiped so you're really able just to
manage your own play and progression and
like okay I'm not gonna like see a map
where it's littered I'm gonna I'm gonna
be able to like pick the missions I want
to do just by talking people in the
world so everything is like just so like
exploration heavy where you're really
just making everything yourself as far
as yeah pretty much mostly good things
and as I mentioned the review in
progress is up on the site right now as
it stands as that as the the real review
in progress stands it's a nine of course
as I mentioned there's still some stuff
to check out to finalize that score but
still that's kind of an indicator right
there but yeah mostly mostly you guys
are having fun which is what matters
really honestly do you have fun playing
a game so yeah like we are all telling
these really funny stories of just
interactions with NPCs it's just such
dumb game play and it's nuts not like a
detriment in any fashion it's just funny
chaotic scenes where it's like the other
day I was showing you that one where I'm
just walking around an outpost I of
liberate and someone just goes you look
over and a bear is storming up outpost
in like ground pounds a red barrel and
the whole thing just explodes in a
matter of seconds you're kind of just
standing there looking at one was dying
laughing but that stuff happens all the
time and it's just it's just chaotic and
fun in that respect so let's pull this
map and I'm gonna get out of this area
do I need to worry about it no you so
like I don't think so we don't need a
worry about anything it's just for the
sake of people who are watching I
wouldn't want to spoil any of the latest
we're not gonna do stories story beats
yeah unless we get cute into another
cutscene now we should be okay see this
area let me double checks what we got
why don't you get one oh yeah that's her
right can you get hurt that's oh yeah we
get hurt so let's do that get hurt sure
we'll go here yeah yeah show me some of
those new vehicles that you got oh look
at that whoa why can't we have a damn
wolf is that DLC dude all I want in life
is a husky so like you know the next
best is a wolf that's your dog of choice
I think well okay yes and no yes in the
sense that if I you know in a perfect
world yes I want a husky the no part
comes because like as most dogs shed
that dog definitely sheds like a lot
right and I don't think I'd want to deal
with cleaning up all that hair but I'd
but I want a big dog anyways personally
like I'm a big dog kind of person yeah
medium sized but you immediate medium to
big size in which case they're probably
gonna shed and all that stuff anyway so
maybe it doesn't really matter and I'm
just been stupid about it oh that guy
what yeah all right where'd he go he saw
you sniping and he was like nah I'm good
all right let's show off some of this
stuff here all right show me show me Rob
so the one way you want them yeah so to
make money I would recommend getting the
Harvard harvest master perk which like
doubles the return you get from like
selling stuff a lot of deer stands and
huh you want to go you want to hunt for
Cougars and black bears those uh-oh 300
what was that that was like a big
antelope I missed it sorry which bears
best Rob which bear his best has had an
office quote yeah black bear Bears beat
Ferris beats Battlestar Galactica what
Michael what's on the right of the
what's this what's this a Wolverine yeah
I had a Wolverine attack the other day
did not go well Wolverines are like V
honey badgers from the previous games
they like
they are they're tough so here's a look
at items you know you can get like body
armor a lot of these things you can end
up crafting like med kits and stuff and
then you have your microtransactions
here this is silver silver bars John
Luke is making a piece today on what
they are yeah so it's the currency is
you look at the top right I believe that
yeah those are silver bars you got
straight bucks though it's like a
hundred silver bars is one dollar what
oh yeah like real world money right so I
was like a dollar there you have 7,000
right so I mean I kill like a couple
more animals I can get this wild goose
or I can spend four bucks someone asked
if there was a sell all button no I
don't think there was you know he's hard
to it's hard now everything well sorry
but uh here's the plan I got immediately
oh yeah wildfire wildfire almost like
it's a Spitfire
he's got the sweet teeth they're the one
bummer about flying planes or vehicles
for that matter is that your your
companions can't get in I mean I know a
bear in the back seat would be
odd-looking but maybe he could Oh they
meet you there that's fine but it's it's
like animal neglect like watch how sad
it is what saved it I guess wow how you
saved that yeah they're pretty generous
with flying Bettina can't wait to place
tomorrow are considering starting to
look at you know release dates and other
games I could come out and the next
biggest one got a warrant got a war and
that's like on 4/20 that's a while is
away so oh and
oh I heard people evaporate when you
drop bombs on
oh that might be my dude sorry killing
you know guys come on
so the flying is like really great I
think helicopters are so kind of finicky
it's cut out audio is cut I don't know
that's one person saying that if anyone
else has that same problem tell me but
as of right now I'm pretty sure it's
just that one person
risky alright so let's do that mission
right yeah we gotta go get hurt still
get hurt
let's go get hurt it sounds like a
personal problem yeah I think so too
[ __ ] math so look at this like the
map is not littered like these are all
so I could go here and get a side
mission or like when you liberate a town
like say what's the big one falls in
trails end sorry fall citizens fail fail
you'll see all these prompts of like
missions here so it's all kind of
centralized supposed to like just
scattered everywhere it's just like far
easier but anyways just to hurt you see
nothing
again we're playing on ps4 Pro yes looks
real good
oh it's here
you might do some PC tomorrow yeah see
how that works out to go on set to play
oh you're a sinner
yes interrupts in this shipment always
going down done yeah he's probably done
he's still good right yeah he's gonna
fix that you can save that oh you don't
get to see them explode you know that's
one thing is like it will or will not
have a sweet explosion I feel like it's
just the distance rendering how about
here
you can pay a thousand dollars
mid-flight to get you that's what's weak
it is like what you it's just every time
you're in a plane it kind of forces you
out I want to say or are you yeah I
would never spend $1,000 I would just
well I was I would just bailed all right
well like arms more ammo but you want
your money to buy weapons and stuff
thousand dollars is it not is like alive
7000 right now
oh that's a plane oh yeah we're gonna
soar like a dogfight yeah like so it
looks battle each area has resistance
right so like the higher like your
resistance is the more like they're
gonna try to take you out yeah oh I have
Rockets too ready
Oh God you did what
you also dodge that somehow what fourth
time's the charm
got him all right let's do you have like
anti-missile stuff if like oh shoot a
missile helicopters have flares yeah
okay all right so I think we refill is
kind of garbage yeah I don't know man I
don't know it's like hey I'm gonna pay
you $1,000 come quickly in a add-on
stuff what is nice is this game has a
pretty sweet customizable like interface
hive type stuff so you can like that's
boomer by the way
he's like just running around trying to
follow me are you doing a great job
have you played co-op no we try playing
co-op here we have weird internet
settings like NAT settings okay mostly
fixed that I feel like we're gonna try
it out and definitely try it tomorrow I
think because someone was asking if
there was a penalty for being too far
from the co-op partner
I thought ya know that apparently there
is
oh I guess we don't say that when
wingsuit so do you lose that plane now
no I just its response whenever I go
back to a runway I can spawn it does
that plane now crash yeah okay I don't
know where why that's fine Oh 360
noscopes I can't really see where Alan
pairs if you check out the review in
progress on gamespot right now you'll
know and you should buy it or not see up
here
we'll find out boomer boomer isn't
peaches uh know it yet hands which yet
or you did switch it and then we had to
get out we did have to get out yeah I
guess there is a vending machine built
in the plane puppy mouth you see that
takes a thousand-dollar bills and then
knows I guess he's behind us it was kind
of hard to spot I guess that's it
no it lands by itself okay I got sharp
in Anna I love how when like your pets
like run in front of you wherever you
are sorry I always want to look at this
pup hey oh so he's great cuz he'll spot
animals because animals will attack you
see boy got got a farm that that skin
good job boomer my shot boomer care sing
again baby
it'd be so great if he could bring back
meat or like loot them off
oh yeah cuz so many times I'll shoot
something on a cliff and then it like
rolls off or like rolls away it's like
dammit I will say this is the first time
in a long time you realize he here we go
so named after the greatest first lady
ever served this fine country of course
if then Obama tires find out that I
can't look after my own property I can
kiss this Senate run goodbye now seeing
as you're on my land and I didn't kill
you even though it's well within my
rights red blooded American gonna say
you owe me help
numbnuts get my truck back so I can
start focusing on my campaign again yeah
he's fun thanks dad
seven Daniel Katzman says how many
weapons did you guys or we're able to
buy without paying for microtransactions
you pretty much bought all your stuff no
I haven't bought all of it yet I'm going
out but like you can buy it you can buy
anything it's almost kind of funny how
even in here like there's us x4 Rob it's
been more fun than farcry yeah or
absolutely absolutely more fun like I'm
not I'm not
burnout or bored of it like you're not
seeing like there a ped of nature of any
of the side stuff like everything seems
like they fresh
we're on a pro right now
[Music]
[Music]
now you can't kill story mission
characters not really even NPCs friendly
NPCs
oh is it standalone that you're asking
no they're wondering if you had to buy
the gold like the old fast boomerangs
never we can buy the Far Cry 5 season
pass on its own is it more fun than Far
Far Cry primal as black what was I like
for more than primal primal I fell off
you didn't sooner I just thought primal
was a little boring
Johnny rile how long are you guys gonna
be stream for right like till 12:30
who's playing rob is playing right now
now this is a pre-recorded video we just
like to come in and chat over it
you are a good listener but that didn't
speak so you know what I have turned on
I'll probably turn off was that is like
this is all pretty great because I feel
like if you notice cool I shall probably
leave that on but like I don't I'm not a
big fan of like the hologram I can turn
that off for friendly but I turned it
off for enemies where it's like you you
just get this gruff like it's a little
overkill it's just a red hologram of
someone who's on the other side of a
wall I find that kind of immersion
braking Steven wants to know how far how
many hours deep are you into the game
I'm like I'd say 15 15 18 hours and I've
been doing a lot of the side stuff
that's really main story oh my god bro
campaign can take you 25 hours or more
that's what our GameSpot's news article
says oh your car is over there where's
Nancy
oh I didn't mean to do that oh no that's
what you get you're the one that fired
off a shot and you know hurts not the
smartest guy no what do you think he's
gonna do a lot of these NPCs aren't the
smartest let me get the Cougar you can
do that mid actually screw it let's get
let's get cheeseburger bear out here oh
you got laser sights on you yeah where
was this guy oh oh he's gonna get lit up
too oh he's totally down oh that's like
force Cup something bit me have you
encountered any bugs yet yeah a few mice
I turn off that Holograms weird you can
get a bear yeah you get a bear or a
cougar or dog so far as far as animals
go yeah and then you have guns for hire
as well oh oh yeah good work
cheeseburger Oh watch out this guy knew
that Gentry right below there trying to
get on that guns hurt again
so like this I can craft a nice remote
explosive rifle on a fly yep no hands
alright are you alright
get him cheeseburger bulb ah so there's
one thing that's frustrating is like
trying to loot someone and and then but
accidentally they go up a weapon well
you could always move his body I guess
that just the mini yeah oh yeah you're
getting too far from your ally Oh what
get your ass over here he's not the
fastest runner okay oh my God look how
slow he is he's got a RPG on his
shoulder Rob realism
he's freaking bear
I like his collars got cheeseburgers I
know yeah Oh mm-hmm don't be a sinner or
that might happen I guess - you will
make it all right
okay that's pretty funny is the
protagonist mute I guess yeah you are
you're telling you I mean hell even
guess me I don't think we said anything
our ghost well it's just far cry 4 he
wasn't cool he would totally nail a tree
go for it dude
okay I want to swap and take the yeah
cool girl
yeah he's very funny oh there goes daddy
yeah Wow he felt the breeze on his oh he
did say that huh yeah don't worry
cheeseburgers oh yeah well I got both of
them how I forgot you could do that you
get both yeah
you have two guns for hire once those
are animals for her okay so ridiculous
okay can we have subtitles please
subtitles sure we can turn those on
absolutely game playing they always
change in different areas no we're video
subtitles you have to hit like a pie or
something
now they're on okay maybe is because
so much I basically raised a man maybe
it's it's yeah this isn't necessarily a
cutscene slamming beers and clams
oh man second coolest dude in the whole
county probably you'd like that people
aren't afraid like hey there's a giant
bear here and a cougar
PTL supposed to follow him I'll be
honest with you man there's real
personal I know they say it ain't never
the kids fault but man I took it to
heart anyway
ran away from home I know how you feel I
was terrified I didn't run away from
high just turned 30 years old and I
didn't know what I was doing man I mean
there was a thrill that came with being
a runaway in a freedom that I cannot
explain I mean that's where I found
myself and that is why I recommend
running away to every child I mean
running in the jungle with the rocket
launchers I mean Eric and someone asked
how many can you use it once it's - I
know it's definitely - followers you can
have that ones I didn't think you do
animal and or to animals you could only
do one animal in one person that's true
hunter I hope you enjoy your stance once
you go it came first the chicken or the
egg
wait are we talking about man
we're we gonna shoot something
No you also have to realize if it's
blurry for you on the stream sometimes
it could just not being able to handle
it also when you stream a game it
doesn't necessarily look exactly the way
it would look like if you're playing oh
these guys are freaking beat oMG yeah
Oh where'd you come from
oh it looked like you're punching and
then not punching
a little slide I like it Oh wall of
cheeseburger
I love the how you can change the rate
of fire on Oregon's got the Nancy truck
right there oh you can get on the turn
oh mama yeah that seems like a good
campaign car you know like yeah because
oh my god so fast this is our family guy
that shows like the Cougar that's
chasing like the kids
oh they give the commercial or it's like
was it fast animal' slow children I got
honey all over my Jeep my knees it's
like this animal spreading toward them
hey guys wait up
oh crap oh I love this song oh man a
church
Robocop huh Creedence
yeah but and to get my explosion oh man
the turret speed is really low I gotta
just know everything like the like turn
rate
yeah the turn rate that's one hell of a
truck yeah
can you ride the Barrett on themselves
now you couldn't crime all which is
bummer for and for the enemy missin
primal
oh hell yeah oh there you go that's what
I want to see yeah some Michael Bay
action there is a lot of in the main
storyline or missions there is a lot of
Michael Bay action just like semi trucks
with machine guns on the front of it
you're doing the exact same thing it's
pretty fun what do you use to record
what do you mean sail over the ocean
blue like this audio this screen
credence plus guns and some beers and
that's Rob's weekend yeah sure
can you do all the story missions go up
you can do the whole game go up there
you go it's just one of you the person
who's hosting the game is the one that
will receive the progress yeah but
apparently even like I can bring over
like my own weapons to vote so if I were
to play in onto your game I could bring
over like oh so you'll still be like
kitted out yeah like like some of that
progression
have you played multiplayer yet not too
much yet Michael Ramos but we plan on
doing that tomorrow if there are bugs
it's like people talking over each other
just having their own inner my log or
monologues no there's - there's like
right now I engaged with him but he's
already talking on his own just because
I was near him no more second he
believes in wuhan back to you what's up
Santiago
the product project coal party project
philosophical Jesus I know right you
like maybe you ever think it alright
let's look at the map and see if we can
take a town here clutch Nixon so he's I
think he's like uh that's the thing
Center on paying centers where I got
cheeseburger well you could always save
that other person you can save yet
either
assuming they're on your map sure let's
let's do something else I want to see
hey okay this is good
I want to show one of these with that so
these are Preppers stashes they're kind
of like they're also side missions but
you at the end of them you are getting
like a weapon or a botch money perks
all right let's perfect once excuse me
they're like but they're fun
so like opposed to something that's like
more like your typical ubisoft like cut
and paste type thing these are like more
like handcrafted like they're like
they're unique they have like a fun
story like for instance there's one that
John Luke mentioned in this guy we're
like he went into a barn and it was end
up being like a maze and at the end was
the stash reward but throughout the barn
there's just beehives everywhere that
you're like walking around they're all
very different you're doing a lot of
different stuff with them and then and
they're generally really fun hello
correct that's perfect are you doing
today he's played roughly 15 hours for
the person asking how far or how much
he's played so far let's get a new
weapon the earlier view seemed to be
positive yeah as I mentioned our review
in progress from Edie I've been trained
currently reviewing progress that the
score is nine will finalize that score
hopefully in the next couple days here
as he probably tests some stuff what's
it's like live live
I like real boring so you can customize
so this you buy with money as well right
or silver technically if you want yeah
so these are each four dollars and this
is just cosmetic right
just cause me anything well I mean right
now I'm no one can see it because I'm
playing single-player but if I were to
play multi-player arcade or co-op yeah
there are apparently some like Easter
Egg type ones like you can look like a
siege character or I heard there's like
a primal skin or something it's a primal
skin yeah I haven't seen that yet I
think oh there's one wow that's pretty
dope so this is tied to Ubisoft club
specifically whoa what's up Filipe or
Filip
well that looks cool yeah and then
weapons a super would buy a weapon I
think I was saving or something did you
do that because someone said customize
your character because someone said
customize your character so maybe you're
ahead of the game but I think I was yeah
so here's some look like that's a cool
pistol I could get
where are the microtransactions these
are some of them so you can see right
here so this is the bottom right silver
I could buy this with in-game just a
currency that I can get from hunting
selling back stuff or I can spend $2
real world money so every hundred silver
dollars are every 100 is roughly he's a
dog roughly a dog 120 silver that you
have now did you get that from the game
I did so you can get it was random I
don't know I think it was actually at
the end of a prepper stash somewhere
positive was saying and Lutz or in safes
or something sometimes there's silver by
yes yes there as well like it's random
but you can do that but right now I
don't have nearly muff enough because I
feel like the most like the minimum
amount of silver dollars we need is like
four I don't know 400 or some like that
are 200 there but I don't want to show
yeah obviously I don't have a whole lot
whoa let's see here
don't you want that match your plane AR
see the shark sure now I don't buy that
please don't how about this like an
old-school classic kind of like I were
like maybe yeah maybe like oh the bow
and arrow is cool I should probably shut
that off
I'll swap that out with my sniper oh I
can get a scope on it
Oh loukas guys are their loot boxes like
in Far Cry 4 or 3 now there's no loot
boxes yeah as well he said you can hunt
and sell your loot and as Rob said one
of your best bets is to get that perk
that kind of gives you double the worth
of your like the skins you you getting
from the animals and stuff like that
whoa that looks like something I would
see in the division yeah
calling a liberator oh yeah you're
absolutely right now all right well I go
how many guns I don't know there's a
whole lot though I won't spend too much
more time in here Oh seconds I shouldn't
I was gonna say I'm gonna be the
internet right now and tell you to like
move on get to the game
oh wait what else okay clothes I showed
ya Megan it doesn't matter you can't see
what I look like oh so you already have
been younger but yeah I think I got this
from a quest I'll be honest what's up
alligator all right let's do this
prepper stash you don't need to spend
money no Akito I think it's just
cosmetic and then like also to like if
you just wanted to speed things up to
buy a gun you could do that but I would
say you definitely don't need to do that
probably shouldn't you bought wizard
says it man I love hanging out with you
guys thanks I assume it's us and the
chat but thank you we appreciate it we
appreciate all you guys and gals hanging
out with us today we'll be back again
tomorrow with more for cardfight far cry
5 I can't talk today it's Monday it is
Monday same way we'll have some cool
co-op stuff hopefully tomorrow that's
the plan at least we got to test some
stuff on our in here in the office but
we should
be good I think Wednesday we're probably
going to check out some Dragon Ball
fighters the DLC Brawly and Bartok will
be out Thursday a I need to talk to Sam
cuz Thursday's or Sam's days and then
Friday of course we'll have Monster
Hunter world Fridays with the community
and then I might even try to play some
starcraft because it's like the 20th
anniversary for that game and boy did I
love that game in high school and a
little bit of college we'll see
I don't live stream it will still do
something on it for sure what are you
checking out for looking for people I'm
doing this my purse - Preppers - yeah
beautiful this is gonna hit me I knew it
yeah pretty good job there pretty good
job good landing way to stick it won't
spawn in things where my boys spawning
things yeah you can spawn your
characters here oh you your guns for
hire these are all in your backup Basin
yeah that's about it
oh so this is I'm talking about there's
like kind of like always a little bit of
story with these things let's read this
will also try to play on PC tomorrow
which some people are commenting about
how PC looks better and all that stuff
which is fair so he says those are in a
pro so he says there's some koltes some
wolves yeah so we framed those wolves
nope no cheeseburger no go cheeseburger
hungry we just wanted to play there come
on
[Music]
like how did he not see the bear and
freak out Oh they've got some wolves
that you got to liberate look at them
like this basically
Oh what was that did he not see it oh
yeah I'd be pissed too
oh thanks oh yeah run run no get away
quick
you got a run you got a run don't let
him get ya good dude I can't believe
you're gonna shoot the wall
what a beautiful Beast no it's good
get him peaches run you're faster than a
cougar I can't believe you're gonna kill
this wolf you just freed it
it's an [ __ ] Oh what's up Steven
Steven jr. hi Liz James she says hey to
me and Rob Rob says hey - hey oh here's
a dude let's have the bear killer Roger
Roger please don't do some spoiling
spoil free here you keep that up I'm
gonna have to time you out what's up
team 11 where they come oh my god it's
an [ __ ] good enough reason smoke oh
he's like one of the Oh was that the
character he's like huffed up on some
stuff yeah there's a drug that the
cultists are using to like almost like a
poison ivy sure deal yeah I saw the
yeah I'm sure they're using the same
drugs like mess with wolves and stuff
got'em call peta all liquored up oh no
they're all sleeping or something oh no
this is like a YouTube video where you
just watch them fight each other Oh see
I shouldn't have chased the other one
you're right cheeseburgers like dude
we're the same get out oh is that dead
[ __ ] oh man what is this
Oh soos but no like he's just sleeping
right there just sleeping yeah blasting
cap huh
this one might be pretty short where's
the stash there's something in here or
shippi I don't see anything else well we
got got oh I'm kind of stuck here really
this is Candace can't be Justin what's
up Brad she's got to be more shangri-la
type missions or not any news is
appreciated yes there are
that's what earlier we were kind of
avoiding Oh in the stream where I
accidentally engaged a story beat there
you go well the game does it
automatically so it was tough to avoid
what oh do I go up I gotta go up
well does it does it tell you you're
done it says well I'm so dumb d alright
these are actually really hard to find
cuz like they're just so obvious I just
wasn't gonna say anything oh really
I wasn't sure mm-hmm I wasn't really it
wasn't it's behind you see I knew that I
was looking around
oh my animals will wait for me I'll be
back later [ __ ] you have a wolf
companion in this I wish wicked wolf at
least not right now wicked wolf ass when
you have a wolf companion yeah yeah
unfortunately no all right I guess I'm
going on here
it would be cool Oh like I can't grapple
look at that no fear I thought you're
gonna parachute or wingsuit I'm getting
drugged up oh are you
okay good yeah it's in the water oh
that's why whenever you see sparkles and
stuff like that you kind of see yourself
I'm it's the water they taint the water
to know convert so back into it oh just
soon because I'm showing it doesn't
really do anything to you
just makes just see stars
it only took 25 minutes to type in but
hey things yeah sorry sorry if I missed
it I do miss questions sometimes I
apologize but if you do repeat your
question but not spam it I generally get
back to it so apologies for that
dylan 2.0 we're playing on a ps4 pro oh
yeah they're they're just dumping it
into the water bunch of a-holes
oh are you are your companions not gonna
be able to get in here probably that's
fine oh maybe you can wake up that wolf
is he sleeping or is he dead
hey you're Versailles how are you what
how did he not see you what he it takes
it takes a while no hey man they're not
this small that's true they are they are
not the sharpest tools they're all
drugged up there huffing huffing it up
you're free now now is the sign you're
probably dead though poor wolf can you
reset the outpost like in Far Cry 3
reset them I don't believe so is this
the new Naruto game I wish anything else
around here
I don't want to leave anything ok let's
keep on keeping our Apple I do like the
grappling in this game it's fun oh how
did you how did you get this in here
good lord
okay so that was it so sometimes these
are shorter this ones this one was kind
of short but it was different treasure
yeah was that it yeah that was it it was
a little shorter than the other ones
I've done oh sweet so this is like some
stuff you get so a bunch of perks here
there's like nuka-cola
sure hey the gold bottle man how'd they
get this helicopter in here through
there let's keep going up people are
saying you can reset them oh really
yeah that's what people would chatter
saying so I'll take their word for it
enough people have said it that I feel
like
oh how do i I can't climb anywhere else
can I swing to the other one and then
you need to get to that one
show me your skin I don't know how I can
do this isn't it's not that other one
it's not out of the rope but it takes so
long to like I can't just like Jarvan
and just start from there then let's see
here you know I mean start on that rope
instead or just vote it that way
can I go just that one well you had you
could grapple there right oh it's the
same one mm-hmm oh wait no I think I can
climb into like well can't you just fast
travel out no I want to keep going up
all right you keep going up I'm gonna
keep reading chat yeah Rob get it right
thanks med Rose someone wants you to try
out the 308 carbine can you play without
companions yeah it's it's actually like
surprisingly like okay here we go hello
- huh lovin whoa like Batman would you
can grab that other rope yeah don't
worry monster he's just he likes
climbing
all right that's it I was really hoping
for some cool anything else oh of course
of course even though I haven't played
this game at all well maybe that little
stash there to the right there
well secret body armor that's about it
okay basically all right what next Rob
what next
where shall we go you do an outpost you
know it's better than climbing fishing
really let's liberate this outpost oh is
that the last guy right there at
moonflower trailer park mm-hmm
you wanna do that or liberate liberate
you do you you do you rewards so how did
you get early access oh we have a review
copy essentially Dylan's code there oh
this is nothing there's nothing there
she's an IV herself oh that's your
poisonous yeah you know that's what she
used to do right she kind of like has
like toxins in a way or what sure yeah I
don't know I'm going I'm sticking with
it what was the gun that someone wanted
to see 305 carbine I think it makes more
money I could probably
course
excus are like oh dang they're all
drugged up huh
does that work oh that's so close oh
come on yeah come closer dude yeah I
like it
this guy is just seeing things
there's a guy up top right there yeah
what is going on here that he won't I
think he's like crazy they're all
drugged up you know look at his eyes
yeah got like Sub Zero eyes oh thanks
cheeseburger and he's dead
yes John ooh letter team 11 Oh home run
okay babies not now he's dead jeez
brutal brutal okay
can you ride the bear no no it is a
bummer you can't I can try that bear
okay let's keep on moving do you know if
there's gonna be a day one patch oh
there's been one or two updates just
patches along the way but yeah I don't
know I I would say yes maybe okay maybe
something for PC team 11 we're
definitely not better there that ninja
no way
Roy good not we're playing on the ps4
pro right now
no no PC tomorrow we'll do TC
so this is something you're doing again
oh man he really got away from me Jesus
for now let's get them so there's a
bunch of different lengths oh shucks
yeah you can loot the trucks you can
save prisoners who've been taken in like
vans just kind of smaller things you can
do in the world are actually pretty fun
she hurt cheeseburger for the windows
gay Oh
the auto driving this game is actually
really good so you can like shoot got
him exactly how I envisioned you
shooting that BLAP it almost yeah it was
like it was over like I was gonna go
down the hill now dammit he definitely
didn't put the brake on
oh here's nothing to is you find these
signs so now bison shows up on my map in
this area so everything that's what's
kind of neat compared to other Ubisoft
games is like everything that you find
that correlates to your map is from you
in the world interacting with people or
signs and stuff it's really going isn't
it I feel like you guys are drugged up
hi have a grenade
he's like oh he kinda disappeared
oh man yowza
what do we get
it's RPG just some ammo nothing great
actually boxes potato man love your vids
keep it up guys thanks appreciate it I
hope you're watching potato mode potato
man mmm are you guys able to have pet
dogs and people really want a wolf slash
to harm times we can bring dogs into the
office and a dog use the choppers no the
dogs don't even come with you to the Oh
a little merchant on the fly I haven't
seen anything like this that's pretty
cool oh you have tell me that name of
the gun again 305 carbine thank you
maybe that doesn't even it was he just
asking if it was yeah he was open for it
could just be streaming Jason I say
basically Jason's asking is the FPS that
bad for ps4 is it the streaming it's
probably the streaming I guess I don't
know I haven't noticed too much
framerate stuff have you know there are
occasionally some like hiccups or
stutters upon going into new area I want
to say it chugs for a second but like as
far as like a does it dip below 30 you
know somebody oh these dudes
yeah there's a cougar cheeseburger can
you slap him how you dead yep you did oh
crap fire doors yeah it is it's but they
still take a bunch of damn oh it's not
oh ammo it still takes a while move
cheeseburger move this isn't gonna go
well okay it's fine no I didn't go off
watch out how long your streaming for
says Claire Miller probably for another
20 30 minutes squeeze we have the full
game so here's an example I I saw this
random guy I let him free and then he'll
tell me like a mission or something
Cole so he just basically gave me an
area a new outpost that I could take
down that's the kind of stuff I kind of
want it in like destiny like on the
planets yeah more I just have more like
NPCs other than rather one or two people
that then give you other missions well I
guess in a way you have beacons but it's
not the same but like they'll give you
like side stuff that's like really
simple you know I mean like that in
general was just an icon on map that's
just been kind of like yeah just they're
regulated right dang those enemies are
stupid yeah they're a little stupid yeah
I've said that a couple times on they're
definitely stupid
let's reprimand this dang in a gtam
there is he just gives you his car cuz
pointed at bow and arrow
Nike if you want to check out how
GameSpot or at least Edmund Tran our
reviewer ad has a reviewing progress Wow
he's dead reviewing progress on the site
right now is currently at a nine for the
Ruby in progress what as mentions it's
not the final score as we still have
another day or two of testing to do so
that was a base jump spot I found no I
owe that sniper class there's a 308 part
line I hope I'm not getting trolled
we'll check it out though
Oh No Oh beautiful he was thinking about
he was gonna give me a prepper stash -
not good
she's gonna give you a prepper stash
yeah that was not good at all
I'm sorry absolutely way to blow it geez
Luke Simpson says 308 carbine was in the
sniper section and can you show us car
customization yeah we can check that out
I have been trying to show well car
customization I haven't looked into but
like there isn't it says plain
customization but I haven't really like
found any options to do so we can do
that after this outpost because when you
get in a post that generally unlocks is
this couch co-op no how long is the game
it's roughly 25 or more hours depending
on you know probably how many side
missions and things you do but that's
roughly how long how big is the map we
can show that later thanks team 11 for
subbing your murder Robert says count
pickles don't text and drive kids it's
fair you definitely shouldn't be doing
that geo a carbines my favorite gun says
Dillon nice I can't tell this guy is
trolling zoo because he keeps telling us
to go fishing he's like this outpost has
fishing oh it's freaking Eric that's my
friend okay you just he's just messing
around he just wants perfect way to
relax after killing 30 people quick
little fish goddamn Eric all he was
saying was like do fishing do fishing my
name's Eric too though
well show fishing later you have to find
a hanger to get the plane load out yeah
you'll see well we'll check that on a
second
should I reserve my money for god of war
instead I mean it's hard to save monster
the otic there's like another month
until then I mean if you want to wait
you can do that obviously we're gonna
review Jonna war I'm definitely
personally more interested in God at war
but that's just because of style of game
for me oh you're going in hi oh
I like this I like this yes get in here
who the bears mauling him
oh sorry peaches Oh peaches oh no I do
yeah you know I did that she just slowly
she's taking a little breather you
killed peaches she's taking a look at
nap huh have you killed any bosses no oh
yeah we almost did in the beginning of
the stream oh we did yeah what it was
engaging good thing we didn't show that
let's ditch
I really want to fit and we really want
to play this but I'm finishing you no
Kuni kubarz that's fair well we got
Joseph asking are you enjoying this
better than FC 4 yeah yeah I am yeah I'm
absolutely enjoying like I punch this no
peaches I know right
our planes more prominent in this game
that's Austin Hughes yeah and the flying
is awesome and really enjoying it cool
hey Scott so there are also challenges
so I just got three perks for it just to
show you how this goes perks obviously
are used for on sturdy otic says I think
I'll buy this to play with my friend and
change the phase of playing on Monster
Hunter yeah so you can always like go
into this menu and just check out ok
what can I do to like you know get more
or ramp up my progression because if I
if I skinned three more caribou then I
get three perk points just pretty great
so that's something I can do if you want
to move faster in this area yeah it's
been some points why not I have more
arrows explosive arrows I haven't seen
that yet shotgun are those final locks
you think those are like tied to bosses
or that's just something you haven't
done yet like if you go up one oh yeah
yes there's one of these is so I have
two of those three lieutenants or those
three areas that killed one of them - a
completed one area then I'm able to have
another weapon slot so that's pretty big
so I would want to do that this is tied
to
unlocking I also have to do with one of
her missions oh this one I want to do
for sure you can like somebody got to
buy that 308 oh for sure
we're currently playing on controller
because we're on ps4 Pro so we're on a
PC it'd be different
obviously just two more guys here - I
have explosive arrows yet oh so I forgot
I never used this stuff Jesus these are
just like perks or buffs excuse me yeah
loot Simpson wants to know when you pick
up a gun you still have them forever in
the shop yes always say whenever you buy
one it's there for free always
nailed it got that hotel
how are you yeah yeah I agree mr.
dreadful of the ten video definitely
insult me on the war as well or I'm more
excited because it pays excitement I
guess and I feel like at least for
myself
we kind of have similar tastes and games
means more or I'd like to think that
Ellie's alright let's see this sniper
there it is only 2,800 bones we can
afford that is there like a sometime oh
here's so here's the old flame so we
would want this for sure right these
virgin Christy really all in on that how
is it how much better is it than the
other one no I don't care it's for the
stream alright for this year look at
what you guys did seven six and I just
wanna see if there's any difference in
like the stat let's tricker HD Rob is
liking it more than four for himself but
that's a personal opinion obviously
alright guess you're gonna have to go
hunting after the stream Muhammad we're
gonna check out co-op tomorrow so come
back and we'll have more to talk about
I can't get any attachments Jason
servantes says God of War lol I'm hyped
for spider-man yeah that's my man yeah
me too absolutely I'm interesting I'm
curious just we've only seen so much
gameplay from that game I'm sure the the
movements gonna feel good I'm just
curious about the rest of it later
waffle wizard Chris Denton wants to know
what difficulty is this on I'm going
normal and do you get asked that at the
start yeah yeah why just scream like we
get out oh because I added a I just
engage debuff so I have an attack buff
on her Oh gotcha okay alright so one of
the perks can get is like a pic lock one
which lets you pick pick doors and safes
nice hey you got some silver bars though
oh I got 40 more and I don't know how
much that's 40 cents if what job Luke
tells us is accurate let's Herc's dead
mission item
I'm just gonna see if I can loot some
stuff do you recall the difficulties I
know there's like a horror
there's just three the three easy normal
heart seems like yeah maybe maybe
there's another one if you beat the game
I don't know like a more difficult one
did you play much much Ghost Recon
wildlands not a whole lot no okay
someone asked it how if it felt like
Ghost Recon wildlands hmm I'd say I'd
say no just because it's first-person I
think there a person in first-person are
very different use that drug to try and
turn it into some kind of weaponized
super bear didn't work sounds like a
crazy please before it kills more people
I'm gonna kill it the judge a bear sure
let's do that that sounds pretty fun
it's like Judge Dredd sure let's uh
let's get boomer back in here a Boomer
City there multiplayer ashtekar yeah
there's co-op which as mentioned what
come tomorrow let's do it stew supreme
again renew karai he's a playing guy he
can just bomb [ __ ] it's got seven total
kills right now yeah later bear hell
yeah so you're like see ya see ya
anymore Mike I wanna get in some kind of
attachment on this thing later Mavros
gaming enjoy your breakfast
whoo
oh you can't afford no scopez bust even
after all that money you just picked up
I wasn't that much money I feel like it
sounds like a cost to me quote of 2018
alright so is there no car or garage
either now I'll just steal this take a
little cougar van I think that's a
definitely setting her miles away let's
see how far actually this is go here
Muffy passenger fast travel go fast
travel engage
you got a busy day today Rob um I don't
know
well I have a busy day today no I don't
okay
how are you playing as forever night we
have a review copy so we have an early
copy essentially all right let's check
out oh okay
what's this ooh you got a card for that
man oh here's another prepper stash
we'll do one of those later those are
ways fun lock car or key card that's
weird I've never seen a key card before
does it feel sad playing the other far
cry games yeah like this is very very
similar to far cry it's like it's almost
it's like the same formula but I want to
say it's like kind of finest and owned
as far as the craziness like I feel like
four was a head still kind of a serious
tone this is just ridiculous stuff and I
think that's what kind of I wanted like
because the biggest laughs I want
outward the hell do I go here I only got
so far out fact I was saying like yeah
like it it just they've really owned
just the ridiculous stuff you can do in
this game I want to say oh oh little car
here huh that's pretty fun and you can
buy customized ATVs cars and trucks here
yeah but I don't know how to get in here
oh yeah sometimes there's like a there's
like a quest or something around here I
could like engage but I'm gonna go back
in here again
Oh what about that other door that was
I'm guessing it doesn't work huh
hmm so like well I'm getting eyes I feel
like there's like a lock or a keycard
excuse me around here somewhere Yankee
he just means that like they've
fine-tuned yeah actually and the biggest
thing that you keep hearing about is
just like when you look at like a
Ubisoft map in general it's like
littered with stuff to do everything you
see here is is something that I have
interacted with opposed to like a map
opening up labrang a tower and it's just
like here's a bunch of stuff to do
what's gratifying is that every time I
play this game I feel like I'm it's like
me personally exploring and getting the
reward out of like finding a quest
personally again and then engaging with
it opposed to me just check listing
things off and so maybe try the roof
which you're on right now yeah I think I
was up here earlier and it was locked so
it's just it's just nice opposed to like
looking at a map and thinking oh god
that's like 200 200 hours worth of
content it's like that door over there
doesn't work either right to your left
here
it's it's just nice to be like have no
mini-map even and just kind of like
explore for yourself
oh that's yeah it was nicked all right
that's pretty cool wow that was a real
fast all right I think we I give up on
this fine plus well we got that car
anyways I hope that made sense to ask
that question although people didn't
want to know about the cars what you
serious joke's on you no car for years
Clark sabotage
oh so this is something I just and this
was a perk I just unlocked you want to
do it sure come use this car so then a
cans
the next tier perk for this is that I
can do it prior I could do it prior to
getting in and then I could RAM some 100
boomer to get over here boomer get over
here now
boomer he's being defined right now is
it actually it should blow up
what's up Jacqueline wait what is this -
again I'm pretty sure it's more like a I
would have assumed that it's like they
get in and then they die from the
sabotage approach of hood sound firing
so I thought it was okay this is the
next one you could I feel like you're
gonna die maybe it's because I couldn't
get in to begin with it's like a bug I
don't know
well well great there you go let's just
go find a car and do this
don't kick that classic car
[Laughter]
great job rod I need to do that I didn't
do anything he just suicide are you sure
you didn't throw the bomb explode it on
the gasoline that was next no that was
impact of him he blew that up all right
well don't worry boomers we were Sky
adrenaline that he can give you that
brings you back to life okay fine I
guess you're right and I'm wrong there
what are we going uh we're getting it oh
the bear we got it we gotta do the bear
oh I'm so distracted all right let's go
do this bear
is there a day/night cycle or is it
mission-based day/night cycle yeah
what's that noise
trouble oh you shot a flare he's calling
for reinforcements how did I not kill
him oh those guys are very much dead
yeah they're dead
backups on the way though Rob you know
what's happening
what already thing not we're good I
think we're good where the hell is Nick
yeah good call let's let's see what he
can do here
Nick come mop them up it was Nick right
no that's Nick
no don't hurt boomer you monster
Oh No
that's a buffalo no was a bison is bison
I think you know I totally was
because never earlier I got in the are
we in the right animal no we're not okay
okay Joseph st. John can you write
elephants or other big animals no you
can't not so far at least but now Rob
physics I don't think he can Oh rocket
that guy fine or give them a bow death
like a lost style oh now you can take
their car though right yeah yeah all
planned what you got
eight dollars great just what we needed
eight dollars let's go to the bear nice
Benjamin pick that up tonight have fun
you have no fear of throwing explosives
like a soft pole she can open her way
now he likes to be up in the action it's
like it's like Goldeneye my friend I
didn't know for the longest time you
could like just like throwing they
quickly detonate remote whines oh yeah
proximity whines hey it with aim B yeah
you know that and he kept killing off my
god he's are you okay boy Jesus you're
lucky he is essentially an
indestructible dog this is one saying if
he could just get in the bed of this
truck then we wouldn't be having that
problem Oh see there you go that's what
you're supposed to do
boom let's go hunting
Oh where's that drugged up yeah you're
drunk it was drugged up it might it may
have just disappeared
nope oh it didn't feel anything
geez are you sure you didn't shoot that
arrow that that strongly but all right
oh you're getting you're gonna huff up
on that yeah this is where the drugs in
these crops here you guys flowers all
right let's move in stars yeah it feels
good dude
whoo play with the golden 50 Cal yeah
good try good try to try where do you
find arrows for the bows oh my god to do
it I'm surprised I didn't see blood also
it did what it was supposed to right
like you you basically don't get to
dilute it cuz you exploded it yeah I
should have done that huh yeah you're
right I got a couple who's shootin
I know boomers on the case though oh boy
good luck bloomer yeah have some
dynamite that worked out you got some 50
cal ammo some bodies that disappeared I
guess yes they disappeared all right
it's more destruction please oh you'll
get some destruction I think we're gonna
have some RPGs CG this bear and bear
action yeah oh you're pretty much at the
cave sweet good luck to you sir oh boy
if you thought cheeseburger with me and
wait till you meet the judge what was up
with what this bear again they like
super all right it's all drugged cuz
yeah they try to drag them all up yeah
he's like a super soldier okay should I
should I ditch the bow and arrow for a
shotgun I kind of think I think so yeah
I think that's a good call
oh my god that guy's in a berry that's
Toya baby here what are you doing it
there for god dammit you can only throw
one at a time like why do you blow I was
up
you killed boomer again god damn it oh
no oh damn he's hella fast I was trying
to like basically have like a net like a
like an exit plan joke's on you
come on boomer we're going home oh he
got you out of his cave pretty quick so
you're trying to set a trap
that's right guide yourself that's right
that's right okay I got this figured out
maybe I can throw a little closer just
throw it on the path that he's coming up
god you're smart that's good yeah
and then as he hits it give him another
one yep in the business I'm real drugged
up here he is he like respawning blah
boomer oh no he was close wasn't boomer
the name of the dog and Independence Day
I think it was [ __ ] Dan he's got red
eyes oh he looks real tired now sorry
but oh wow
Oh is he dead why that looked like it
yeah yeah how'd you like that RP Oh
possesses some beat bear get returned to
close it's alright
give it to him again he's still alive oh
he doesn't like Dave oh oh wait is that
his help there yeah yeah one more rocket
yeah yeah 850 bucks yeah wait the judge
bear ooh you're guilty sentenced to life
in a cave I don't know I'm sorry I'm
sorry job good guy buddy I can't pet him
I want you you can sell animal skins for
a good price at any shop Rob hmm
noted yeah your skin could you skin that
bear yeah I did okay he was elute it oh
no four bucks they're all actually that
was buckaroos hat little hat there I
should feel bad for that one why why
that bear had red eyes red eyes black
dragon all right let's go do another
prepper stash those are always fun and
they're different little Preppers -
whelp ramp all right so let's see what
was that yeah the one I just picked up
it should pop up in the area guess not
or I should be able to do
[Music]
this yeah oh wait is that radioactive
waste damn it it's a mutant possessed oh
I got a sweet car if I do this I should
do it look at that
Pygmalion SS are I'm in I think we'll go
out on that after after he gets a sweet
car okay no nice try in the area
watch it doesn't gonna work and then
I'll be sad you're growing our prepper
stash nice is it thick and full or is it
kind of like one of those really like
gentlemanly like I can op Elise tile
ones I can't even I can't really hear oh
I just have to glue it on
oh this is psy pro food and ski so this
is probably that huh that guy yeah this
car yeah makes sense huh make sense Rob
are you coming back in here find the key
so this is quite literally what we were
doing earlier oh that was the part of
the okay I mean you know I don't know it
like even more and it's here right yeah
fasteners got some fasteners oh we're
good we're gonna find it I know I know
now we're totally gonna find it I'm in
here I like your confidence
oh hello that noise
okay I'll kill you geez that thing is
resilient AF I know man
holy smokes oh is that it there was
something in the bathroom oh well have
oh I haven't done oregano I don't have
any surprisingly good and brownies we're
gonna have to try some of this and this
I don't know what this does you're gonna
there are people here aren't there yeah
you're gonna get the crop you're
crossfade on yeah let's do right now
okay we're gonna get across bait on guys
that was a Wolverine not a honey badger
so we're still looking for the car keys
though or the key to the garage I guess
which is not around for whatever reason
well I'm stone dude are you yeah well
did you also drink or just only smoke I
could yeah look at how strong you are
oh there's the roof Hey no you know
where that is still didn't find the key
card hanging over the toilet
Oh card on the wall mr. dreadful please
don't do it oh yes you were right and we
were blind thank you thank God I saw it
thank you I love it when I love that
though I I feel you on that it's like
when you see
oh no boomer oh I wish you 360 noscope
Josh it might as well just like well now
we see Z a mr. jet full we good good
good shout close call Tay you know we do
our best here all right so you can go oh
you didn't have a chance get rid of that
tunnel vision Ari I'll try it's gone
let's try this now drunk driving
whoa this is crazy
all right why don't you go drink and
drive here
are you ready drink I should be here
how'd you go drive do not drink and
drive is terrible you don't want to get
a DUI it's a very expensive and you
can't drive for a long time so don't
hell yes now customize oh wow
oh we rich and we got perks and we got
perks perk magazines here
score some phone call phone call more
money Mo Money mo problems though Rob
don't you know I do oh so wait do you
now have access to customize a car like
this you see yeah alright whoever wanted
to see car customization we got that oh
yeah
oh we got no money there oh but there's
the car that's a Gotham Oh beers so I
have this car Uncle Sam that's pretty
sweet
so this I'm talking about okay so you
can customize oh I can customize this
what can I do
oh you just can put interior stuff on
that's that other one that the Ubisoft
Club one
and Rabbids of course there's Rapids
some standard cars okay so so this is
what I figured is like fresh coat yeah
the standard cars you can customize and
it looks like it's just gonna be skins
and stuff and bobbleheads and
bobbleheads but as far as like what's I
can't customize that same here oh I have
this truck this one has a minigun on it
dude do you see that that's sick lawn
mower though or not lawn mower which we
call it it was like a all the way back
up top to this no higher no you're in
the right thing that thing right there
yeah tractor tractor farm simulator baby
see how this car is though looks nice
oh I didn't spawn it with the bubble it
is that really bad I want to see it okay
I'm curious okay fine it's your car
what is this from
deliver that car delivered are you sure
that's the right card nope
hell yeah what is that next radios
lookit look at that in the background oh
is that the Bison I killed earlier oh no
better so we're all on her own
it was just rolling around hey we just
got this car stopped shooting
guys pretty sweet all right
suffice is not an off-road car Rob but
all right
bobblehead worth I guess so I see one
more thing oh I'm not sure a question
marks if there's a Easter Egg for Blood
Dragon there might be there's supposedly
like like a like a cosmetic of like Far
Cry primal they can put on and there was
like a rainbow succeed one so I'm sure
there's a bunch of Easter eggs that
we're gonna try to figure out and put up
for y'all Dan this would be cool do you
basically just armed your car with
explosives so when it collides and
something to explode so you just like go
to an outpost with like a truck or
something and just get full speed and
ditch it so what now should we call it
or do you want to do it one more thing
how we doing we can do one more thing
okay I'm down
what is one more thing we can do what
haven't we shown you we did our posts we
could go say that dude this last let's
do it alright
hopefully it's not like a Multi quest
thing I'm adding ammo in this
oh well over again the car oh wait you
can't see you there
you definitely see you there I'll stir
to get there I totally have any good
ammo
sir
please stop your vehicle see if woof
how we go
trying to escape what do you think
what you think you're going
flap flap gotcha
I don't know how you got him but all
right uh-oh doesn't have to all make
sense
where's Nick calling your aerial buddy
oh did he is he gone
yeah he's not ready yeah well then well
let's do this let's do Herc
he'll come blow them up I do this what
you got what you got
perfect yeah that answered that mmm I
wish her areas yeah we'll use it later
that's a civilian I'm sorry good thing
your aim is terrible
get in got it
good thing my name is the terrible
absolutely all right gonna try to free
our other buddy here boomer I call it a
scam after that but thank you all for
tuning in we're gonna check out more Far
Cry 5 tomorrow we're gonna try to get
into some co-op potentially the PC so
you can check out that will get you kind
of like a double whammy there and then
there's more streams the rest a week of
course 11 a.m. so please come by say hi
hang out mm-hmm chillax all that fun
stuff we appreciate it
which you could make the music louder
can't really customize that oh I can
customize that by just turning it up
yeah but you still get more car noise
[Music]
thanks Warren enjoyed great Oh Kirk
shoot him
what what what what
what are we on are we on some marijuana
some drug is this a story beat I think
so should I cut away I don't know do we
care depends
yeah it's story beat I think we're gonna
call it there welcome to the Bliss
everyone uh-uh
as mentioned we'll be back tomorrow with
more for Chi 5 thank you guys all for
tuning in and hanging out with this that
was some of the stuff you can do like
mid to late game Rob was in about 15
hours or so you know car customization
gun customization different side quests
and things you can do totally a story
beat totally I'm glad we got away all
those fun animals you get to control and
stick on people yeah so yeah check out
the review in progress from edy that's
up currently the score for the review in
progress is at 9 but of course that's
not the final score once it kind of
locks that down you'll see that change
over to final review and yeah come back
tomorrow and the rest of this week's
from PC and co-op I think tomorrow yeah
that's LAN yeah anyways thank you guys
all as usual and have a good rest of
your what's today Monday geez Monday
yeah happy Monday bye
[Music]